hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in cicero's work on morale ends he has
one character Lukas torquatus who
represents the Epicurean position and
who presents it in a extended argument
trying to make the case for what it is
that Epicurus actually thinks and that
it's quite rational and should be taken
as the correct philosophical position in
ethics and the Epicureans are hedonist
that means that they believe that
pleasure is not just something that's
good they believe it is the good or to
put it in Cicero's terms the Summum
bonum the greatest the highest good the
good that in some respect encompasses
the other ones and makes them good
likewise it's called on the ends not on
the end because pain is also an end a so
mama but it's the Summum Mahlum the
worst evil and so pain is not just
something bad for the Epicureans it is
love bad it is what is worst
and what makes other things bad so good
and bad are understood primarily in
terms of pain and pleasure what about
everything else in the universe that
we're interested in that might motivate
us that we might take into account in
our moral reasoning or even in our just
sentimental responses well everything
else for the Epicureans is simply a
means to an end and we have two
different ends here the end of good and
the end of evil or badness so everything
that can bring us to some sort of
pleasure is conducing to that final end
of ours which is to have pleasure to
enjoy pleasure or to avoid pain likewise
there are many things that are bad not
intrinsically bad but because they lead
to pain
so the Epicureans might take some things
that we would often say are just good or
just bad and say well no it really
depends on whether they're leading to
pain or pleasure or are likely to lead
to pain and pleasure and that's a
typical hedonist position now Cicero is
going to have torquatus provide several
arguments explaining the epicurean
position trying to make it seem
reasonable and plausible let's take a
look at the first argument it's fairly
straightforward this is one that comes
directly if the ancients are correct
from Epicurus himself which is that
every single animal when we observe them
as soon as they are babies they desire
they seek out and they enjoy pleasures
their pleasures may vary considerably
from species to species so we share some
things in common for example with otters
we both enjoy swimming and playing in
the water but otters eat a lot of things
that I think we would find fairly
disgusting and perhaps vice versa
there's probably a lot of things that we
eat that otters would turn their nose up
at and if we go through other animals
we'll find all sorts of other things
that that we don't enjoy that they enjoy
and vice versa and there's some things
that babies do enjoy that perhaps we as
adults don't get so much out of and vice
versa you know you're not gonna have a
baby enjoying reading Cicero for example
but every animal does in fact desire and
seek out pleasure from it's very
inception from its very birth
likewise Cicero has torquatus say they
do the converse with pain they register
pain and it sucks for them they don't
like it they do the opposite of desiring
which is being averse to they do the
opposite of seeking which is to avoid
now Cicero says this this assumes
you've got an animal whose nature has
not been corrupted if it has been
corrupted then you might say all bets
are off but you don't take those as the
norm so looking at healthy animals from
their very inception they begin to value
pleasure as the highest good does this
actually prove that pleasure is the
highest good if you want to be strict
about it not really it does prove that
pleasure is a desirable good and that
animals are motivated by it and likewise
they're also motivated to avoid pain but
it doesn't prove that it's the highest
good a stronger argument is going to be
provided for this a little bit later
let's look at the second argument also
not that strong but an interesting one
nonetheless so it's saying essentially
there is an immediacy about pleasure and
pain that doesn't require any sort of
complex philosophical argument on their
behalf as fundamentally basic for ethics
what's the argument here well we grasp
pleasures desirability through our
senses how do you know something is
pleasant well you know I'll be kind of
silly here give it a lick give it a
touch give it a tickle smell it rub your
face in it you know that works for
certain kinds of things you might
imagine a bar of chocolate right give it
a lick you know that's very pleasant rub
it on your face maybe not so much maybe
it's not that kind of pleasure right and
likewise how do you know something is
painful well it hurts you or it sucks
and it makes you feel bad some pains
could be maybe not like the poking like
you know something poking you in the eye
or catching your toe on the stool or
something like that but there's other
things like the gross feeling of oozy
things right you you recoil from that
you don't have to sit there and think
hmm is this something that is actually
painful to me I don't know let me go
through a syllogism Epicure says
you don't have to do anything remotely
like that you know right away that
something is pleasurable and painful and
we know right away that we are motivated
by these things a much stronger argument
is provided in claiming that pleasure
and pain are are generating or
determining the motivations that we have
our fundamental attitudes and behavior
and relations to all other things so
he's going to say this in two places in
the first place
he is going to say that we seek out
pleasure and and and we avoid pain and
that leads us to other things as well
he says what is nature perceive or what
does she judge of perceive through the
senses judge of through the intellect
besides pleasure and pain to guide her
actions of desire and avoidance desire
and avoidance are in some respect
dictated or determined by the pleasures
and pains that we've experienced or that
we anticipate coming from whatever it is
that we're reasoning about or even just
reacting to a little bit later he'll say
pleasure and pain supply the motives of
desire and avoidance and the springs of
conduct generally so the idea here is
that if we're looking at human
experience if we're generalizing about
the kind of creatures that we are and
we're being honest with ourselves we
will will will understand that pleasure
and pain lie at the basis not only of
everything we do but everything we think
everything we feel even more so
everything we value and how we value
things in relation to each other
seems to be a somewhat stronger way of
making the case the fourth argument that
he's going to provide and you see him
doing this in many different ways
talking for example about friendship or
about virtue or about other things that
we we choose and pursue is that any sort
of exception what seems like an
exception to the rule of pleasure and
pain are really the fundamental
motivators can actually be explained in
terms of pleasure and pain
so take the virtues for example are the
virtues genuinely good do we really
value courage justice temperance wisdom
for their own sake or do we value these
because they lead us to pleasure and it
help us to avoid pain or at least to
minimize the pain that we encounter what
about the vices are they bad in and of
themselves folly cowardice injustice in
temperance or are they bad because they
ultimately lead to pains and deprive us
of pleasures we can talk about
friendship
but Epicurus also goes to ordinary
experiences that we have think about
when you forgo some sort of pleasure
that you normally would pursue because
you engage in some reasoning and you
realize that if you do engage in this
pleasure you're going to have a more
painful situation later on think for
example about when you'd like to say
something cutting two or witty but kind
of biting to somebody else and you think
oh no no I better not say that now why
do you forego that immediate pleasure
it's because you actually do value
pleasure more and you want to have more
pleasure later on than right now
likewise why do we do the things that we
do that don't bring us pleasure in many
cases to avoid pain
to avoid further pains down the line and
so any sort of exception according to
the Epicureans can really be explained
in terms of good practical reasoning
that leads us to enjoy pleasure is the
good and avoid pain as the evil this
according to torquatus and Epicurus
provides the fundamental basis for not
just epicurean ethics but for all other
ethics it's just the Epicureans are
being honest about it and everybody else
is sort of hiding this from themselves
you